hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and in the course of doing many
podcasts interesting phenomena arise
when I look at what the comments are and
from various sources whether it's email
or Twitter or comments on the web page
or on YouTube or reddit different
podcast episodes have different spirits
in some sense sometimes we're big
picture right we're sort of talking
about various ideas from a very
high-level view and it's more
inspirational than challenging right
it's like thinking about things rather
than getting a lecture in them other
times we get a little deeper we kind of
get our hands dirty we get into the
weeds we try to dig into some specific
example of something either way I will
get complaints that has had I know and
you know what I love and cherish the
complaints because I want to
constructive feedback I want to hear
what people have to say
but honestly going forward realistically
it's going to be a mix of both kinds so
today we're getting our hands dirty
we're gonna get into the weeds don't be
afraid you know don't think that well
this is gonna be a slog or anything like
that this is one of the most fascinating
episodes I think that I've done here on
mindscape and perhaps the most useful in
a sense I will explain to you in just a
second our guest is Karl frist in who's
a neuroscientist at University College
London and Carl Fishman is by many
measures at the most influential
neuroscientist
alive today the most citations the
highest h-index all these different
quantitative measure of scientific
success he is a practicing psychiatrist
and is very interested in schizophrenia
and he serves patients but he is also
contributed to neuroscience more broadly
most obviously in developing techniques
for imaging the brain ideas like
statistical parametric mapping
voxel-based morphometry I really have no
idea what these ideas are sorry about
that what I'm interested in is where
he's moved more recently in his career
into the theory of how the brain works
and he's been developing an idea called
the free energy principle as part of a
bigger set of ideas called the Bayes
Xion brain the idea that what the brain
is trying to do is to model the world
around it and therefore develop a little
picture of what's going to happen next
using Bayesian inference something you
all are experts on because you've all
read the big picture or somewhere else
Bayesian inference is getting data in
and using that data to update your
beliefs about the world the free energy
principle is Kristin's idea for how the
brain effectively does that it turns out
that calculation alee updating your
beliefs about the world can be very very
hard the free energy principle is a way
to sort of simply and quickly get to an
effective view of the world and the
basic idea is that the brain is
constantly trying to minimize surprise
is trying to develop a model for all the
stimulus all the sensory input that it's
going to get that is least likely to be
surprised by something new happening so
that sounds simple but when you get into
it when you look at the actual way it's
supposed to work it actually turns out
to be pretty darn complicated and
intimidating and famously there's a
large number of people in a lot of
different fields not just neuroscience
but deep learning machine learning
biologists and physicists and a whole
bunch of people who have trouble really
figuring out what this is all about so I
really think that in this podcast we
present quite an understandable picture
of what it's all about there's some
jargon Polly explain what the jargon is
of course Carl understands what it's all
about but I think that we're able to
give enough examples talk a little bit
about why the brain would work this way
and what it's supposed to be why in
particular he's interested in it from
the point of view of addressing
schizophrenia and other problems and to
me of course I'm biased I know a lot
about free energy and entropy and
measures of information theory etc but I
think we did a good job of uncovering
what's going on here you know there's no
equations in the podcast but the ideas I
think are out there this is the kind of
episode which it really repays listening
closely to I think you can learn a lot
and learn about something that is really
at the absolute cutting edge of modern
neuroscience I also want to mention a
tiny little announcement you know that I
have a patreon account that you can find
on the
page four Posterous universe calm /
podcast there's a link to the patreon
one of the benefits the patreon users
get is that they get a monthly asking me
anything episode so patreon users ask me
questions I try to answer as many of
them as I can
and someone on patreon suggested that
even though it makes sense the patreon
supporters get the ability to ask
questions the ability to listen to the
answers might be more widely shared so
I'm working out a way to do that every
month there's like a two or three hour
episode that I put on patreon and right
now it is only for patreon listeners but
going forward I'm gonna try to figure
out how to make those answers available
to anyone right now the only way to do
it is going to be to go to the patreon
page every month when they appear but
hopefully I'll figure out a way to put
them into the regular podcast feed the
trick is that it cost me a lot of money
to put two or three hours worth of
gigabytes of data on to the podcast feed
because my host is really expensive it
gets paid for by the ads it's not clear
whether we can get ads to pay for the
AMA or not let me know you know
especially on the comments in the in the
blog post associated with this
particular episode whether or not this
is a good idea at all whether people
would be interested would it make sense
just to include like one hours worth of
answers then you can go to the patreon
page to get the rest etcetera etc but I
think it's a different kind of thing
it's not going to replace regular
mindscape episodes but it might be a
different way to get some ideas out
there and talk about them and with that
let's go
call first and welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you I'd like to be I
figured we would talk about this thing
called the free energy principle which
you've been investigating and
championing for a while now but maybe
just to get there rather than just start
by defining that could you just explain
what is the problem that we're trying to
solve what is the question that we're
trying to answer by talking about free
energy from my perspective it's trying
to find a first principle account of
sentient behavior and just very
practically that's relevant because of
my background which is a psychiatrist so
very simply lesson Richard Fineman says
if you want to understand something you
gotta be able to build it if you want to
understand psychiatric patients you have
to in some minimal way be able to build
or simulate scenting behavior that goes
wrong okay so that's basically how I got
into it so you were actually a
practitioner with patients and the whole
oh yes transitioned out of that yes
slowly but surely as Kant transferred my
angst from patients to students okay to
spend you know an early part of my life
in a therapeutic community with 30
chronic schizophrenic
which was an eye-opener for several
years I can imagine yeah okay and so
that so we want to understand how the
mind works how the brain works in part
to help fix it when it goes wrong that's
the ultimate agenda because I got
seduced away from clinical psychiatry
into systems neuroscience and brain
imaging and the question became slightly
less focused and more how does the brain
work and that became relevant when
you're trying to characterize or analyze
neuroimaging time series from things
like functional magnetic resonance
imaging go on the electrical decathlon
Rafi so you to make sense of these data
you have to have some conceptual charity
or Ford model of what's actually under
the horn sure otherwise it's just a
bunch of time series data
yeah but and neuroimaging is sort of
where you made your money as it were
right that's that's my I'm thinking
about the grand theory of the brain is
what we're doing now so good so that's
enough for me to dive into free energy
except that you had this lovely story
that I've heard
about woodlice when you were young and
seeing them scurry around that does set
the stage very nicely if you could tell
our listeners that story right well that
was my first looking back my first sort
of scientific insight so it was a hot
summer's day and I was must being about
between 5 or 8 years of age playing in
the garden and just became preoccupied
by watching little woodlice is going
around noticing that they tended to
avoid sunlight that they ended up in
underneath little bits of rock award in
shady places I'm just looking at this I
thought that's interesting because that
looks like purposeful behavior it looks
as if there are they are purposefully in
a goal-directed way avoiding the
sunlight but then there was another
interpretation that came to mind well
yes but you would also see exactly the
same phenomenology if they just moved
more quickly when they were warmed up by
the Sun so there was a more deflationary
camera didn't use these words of the
essence of an of the insight was well
there's a much simpler explanation of
what's going on here for this very
elemental form of self-organization
ensemble dynamics there's a simple
explanation things just move fast when
the hotter that notion that sort of
deflationary simple almost verging on a
tautology explanation for
self-organizing behavior kept sort of
representing itself throughout my
education sort of natural selection I
think is a nice example of that if it
doesn't work he move in some phenotypic
space right through to physics at
Cambridge in sort of this genomics and
the [ __ ] plank and quantum physics
again if it's a you know if it's not
good if it has a high potential just get
out of there were you a physics
undergraduate that would Eastern Natural
Sciences yeah so half psychology and
half physics and quantum physics I had
no idea the sole audience don't you know
but I don't seek out people who were
physics undergraduates but I find that
but in a deflation way just because to
move away from people that's right
exactly so I love that kind of story
because it's an example of what I talk
about a lot in the big picture these
this emergence of purportedly higher
well purportedly purposeful teleological
goal directed behavior out of you know
things just obeying the laws of physics
one way or the other right and that's so
that's the kind of thing that you saw in
your undergraduate education and even
today I presume in studying the brain
yes well I mean at its heart that that
is the free energy principle that you
know you know we've been promoting it is
very much this of deflationary getting
back to the first principles and then
rebuilding up on that and see what would
this kind of behavior look like in a
sufficiently itinerant context yeah how
would it would it be fit the purpose to
explain the behavior of you and me or
starting that's slightly simpler level
would it be fit for purpose and
expending a thermostat or a virus or
something or ensemble of bacteria or
other like so it's question of how far
can you get from first principles as a
principal account of sentient behavior
so we get back to the human brain and of
course that is in terms of writing down
the dynamics the mechanics and
specifically in mathematical terms is
becomes a necessary if you want to write
down formal models of brain imaging time
series so there's an interesting
dialogue between the the the rather
self-indulgent theoretical neurobiology
side of it yeah what are often referred
to as you the work that you do that we
can do it when the pressures are off and
the day job which is analyzing print
brain data right both sides inherit from
each other in a very interesting way
that you you're you're constantly
building models of how the brain works
and then testing those models
in relation to the empirical data you
get from brain imaging which forces you
thoughts pressure on you to actually
sort of think more what's the simplest
sort of dynamical functional
computational architecture that could
possibly explain these data when I look
at this sentient creature than usually a
normal subject human subject when
exposed to these experimental
manipulations and yet on the other side
the very algorithms themes or data
analytic approaches that you apply to
make the inference about you know is
this the right model of the brain or is
that the right model the brain
themselves now become inherit from the
theoretical word because if you saw how
our brain works that's the best sort of
data right now is this machine you can
possibly out and then that helps with
analyzing the actual data has it
affected what data you collect yes yes I
mean that's true both says it's true in
terms of me as a sentient creature in
this very example yes I looking around
and I'm literally collecting visual data
as that's the card around the room
interrogating your face trying to
anticipate whose turn it is to talk your
whether you've understood me so I'm
selectively something the right kind of
data to resolve uncertainty about those
hypotheses that I'm relevant to my
behavior at the moment were and in
exactly the same way as a you know as a
new imaging scientist I designed those
experiments to solicit the right kind of
data that resolve my own certainty about
my hypothesis about the functional
integration of the hippocampus with the
prefrontal cortex same stuff it's
exactly the same principles good except
now I'm self-conscious that everything
that I do you're anyway I mean of course
you're gonna be looking in my face in a
different way than you're looking at the
desk in front of you which you see every
day right the surprise all the new
information is much larger for something
like that so okay good what is free
energy when you think about it I because
I'm a physicist and I have a definition
and I think it's a little bit different
than yours but there's a mathematical
relationship so I want to clear up for
everyone in the audience what we mean
when we use these words right so
when I talk or when people that I'll say
I have it self-centered when people in
things like machine learning talked
about feeling G they mean variational
free energy so technically if you were
talking to somebody from machine
learning we're talking about an evidence
low upper bound if they switch the sign
in machine feelings so often called an
evidence lower bound acronym elbow which
confused me for enormous that I
literally thought whose part of your
body for trouble really
so it's it's a statistical information
is theoretical concept which licenses
your previous discussion about
hypotheses and inferring this and rich
information so it's calls basically a
bound on the technically the self
information or the log probability of
some data given a model of how those
data were generated so from a pure so
sorry that's the crucial thing there's a
model and there's data yeah and we would
like them to match yes absolutely so
well let's just rehearse
that's absolutely fundamentals yeah
everything that we talked about either
in terms of sort of sentient behaviors
the energy principle as applied to
sentient artifacts or in terms of
actually analyzing data rests upon this
notion of a generative model generating
what generating data generating
sensations generating any observables
and an even more simple expression of
that is you have to have some way of
articulating and mechanics of causes and
consequences hmm so the generative model
causes or is a description of how causes
generate consequences and in this
instance the consequences are sensory
observations or data observables
measurables the causes are the sort of
the latent variables features structures
whatever you want to call them that are
responsible for generating those things
so
central to the free-energy as a scalar
functional is a guaranteed model so it's
only defined in relation to a genitive
model that tells you meet it in the free
energy the variational Ferengi is a
functional function of a function and
the function is a function of is a
probability distribution or a belief so
so this is your brain giving
probabilities to the various things it
might experience out there in the world
and and the free energy is a way of
measuring it all to say relating those
that prediction for what you see to what
you actually see and then sort of what
what measure is it what does it
characterize really well exactly as you
as you defined it it's an a measure of
the the supplies that you would have and
I'm using surprising in a sort of year
well at least a full folklore sense
there folk psychology sense that but
literally that surprised all the self
inflation there is a technical version
of it which is in this case pretty close
to the full version so it's the the
surprise that you would associate with a
bunch of data given a belief or a model
about how those data were generated so
technically it's also called the
marginal likelihood or the logarithm the
negative logarithm of the marginal
likelihood and that marginal likelihood
is also called a model evidence and all
this rhetoric becomes important because
as you know you can gracefully move from
one interpretational stance to another
one without making any mathematical
Meuse whatsoever right the math is
carries over just exactly the same but
depending upon how you grew up or how
you appreciate these quantities avoid
the rhetoric that you would interpret
them you get a very different look and
feel to the fundamental behavior of
systems that look as if they are
minimizing the variational free-energy
so if this surprise is interpreted from
the point of view of a statistician so
the brain as the status as dis glorg and
a little a little scientist inside your
then if it is in the game of minimizing
its variation Ferengi
it's evidence bound that makes it appear
as if it is maximizing model evidence
what does that mean well it will look as
if it's gathering information in the
service of seeking evidence for its own
existence and this translates nicely
into a philosophical concept
self-evident thing so another way of
looking at this purely mathematical sort
of behavior is in terms of self
evidencing so you have lovely little
phrases like you know people going
around gathering evidence for their own
existence oh yeah mathematically a
truism yeah so that's only one or you
can look at it the other way around
we're trying to minimize surprise so
what would that look like if you were in
it you know you've been taught to think
about things in terms of information
theory and uncertainty well
mathematically expected surprise
expected self information is entropy
entropy is one way of describing
uncertainty so what does that mean it
means that you look as if this creature
or this artifact or this system is
gathering information in the service of
resolving uncertainty uncertainty
relation to its model of how we think
the world works and in particular how it
is situated within that world and
sampling from from that world
so that brings us back to your phrase
earlier on about looking around not
looking at my guess because there's no
which information there may be surprise
hopefully I should just erasure I
haven't got my glasses on so I can't see
so so you know what is another way in
information theory of articulating the
notion of rich information
it's just minimize the uncertainty and
it's maximizing the relative entropy as
scored by the technically the KL
divergence that is part of an expected
free energy but put more simply just
means that minimizing free energy or
making moves that will minimize the
energy in the future simply means
maximizing information gain or
optimizing some divergence measure
literally making your mind up in the
sense of moving a belief moving a
probability distribution from one prior
belief to a posterior belief and the
more information that you you you you
can I have at hand you will assimilate
and the counted versions fallen
assistance be be greater and that's a
very important part of the when you
actually write down the imperatives for
action that becomes a very very
important part and this kind of makes
intuitive sense right that our brain
would like to carry around with it of
model of the world such that it
typically looks around and says yes
that's more or less what I would have
expected
right and so the free energy is the
difference between what it's sort of
expecting and what it's seeing so who
wants to minimize that and it's
completely information theoretic which I
need to say out loud because of course
the word energy appears in it and as a
physicist we have a notion of free
energy that it's a kind of energy you
can use to do useful work and in fact in
a thermodynamic system when you maximize
entropy you're minimizing free energy
and vice-versa like if you have a box of
gas that is that in equilibrium it has
no free energy lots of entropy
if it's all bundled up on one side it's
the opposite but you're looking at a
context in which the brain is both
minimizing and kind of entropy and
minimizing a kind of free energy that's
a great paradox it yes but we are we are
right in the in the depths of it's the
weeds yeah ok so I apologize in advance
so let's just back happen it'll pay off
later well you know we'll bring it under
don't worry ok so let's just start from
you know you can't you can't university
you've learned that free energy is that
amount of energy that is available to do
work that there's not locked into the
entropy so many on the total entropy is
the expected energy minus the entropy so
what that would suggest in terms
so the first thing to acknowledge is
that the the form of the the free of the
variational free energy is formally
identical to a sort of you know I gives
off them and it's a same equation it's
the same equation they only move you
make is you drop those constant from the
Shannon entropy that as all you do we
said it equals one anyway so it doesn't
agree different language and on that
view what does that mean well that means
if you now write down the energy as a
potential a potential energy and I'm
thinking now from the point of view of a
statistician for example what's the
potential energy that gets into the
variational for energy well it's
effectively the accuracy so it's it's
the the negative of probability of
getting these data given the parameters
of my Charenton model given all the
variables the quantities the structure
of my model of what could have caused
the state of the my hypothesis if you
like there is parametrized and that's
quite important so the accuracy is this
basically the surprise that we were
talking about before I should say the
way that you described you know it makes
sense having a model in the world who
can make predictions and then we can
test those predictions against sensory
impressions absolutely spot-on and
indeed there's a whole industry and both
in terms of data compression and
engineering but also more recently in
neuroscience and cognitive neuroscience
that is predicated on predictive coding
which is exactly that so prediction
errors are just the mismatch between
what you you're gently model predicted
and what you actually sample you take
the sum of squared prediction errors you
weight them by some precision or inverse
variance that is basically free energy
you know it's just under some simple
assumptions about the German model and
you know the nature of random
fluctuations so particular coating is
one instance of the more general notion
that we're in the game of minimizing our
free energy so coming back to this the
other physicist conception of of free
energy in
in systems that have attained
equilibrium what does it then mean to
minimize the Ferengi while you're trying
to minimize your energy which is
maximizing your accuracy for minimizing
the surprise averaging how your
ignorance about the parameters and then
you're trying to maximize the entropy no
that's may seem paradoxical which is why
it's good the yeah I apologize
we're gonna have to resolve so I've just
said if you remember minimizing
uncertainty by choosing the right moves
that will get the most information
resolved a greater uncertainty looks as
if it's trying to maximize the
information you know the relative
entropy but now I'm saying well
minimizing for energy will require a
maximization of entropy from the
physicists point of view yeah and that's
absolutely right so the key distinction
is basically what I do at this moment in
time will always be to maximize my
accuracy or my energy in terms of
minimizing this sort of prediction error
whilst at the same time maximizing my
entropy even my options open because the
entropy that we're talking about it is
an attribute of a belief about the
causes of my data so this is not an
entropy measure of the brain by
physically right it's not the molecules
in your brain we're treating as a
thermodynamic system it's a set of
beliefs absolutely so these beliefs are
then driven to be as broad as possible
it's entirely consistent with you know
the second law of thermodynamics there's
an imperative as a driver disorder the
entropy will increase but it's the
entropy of our beliefs now what does
that mean well it basically means I'm
trying to find a low-energy explanation
for my for my data whilst at the same
time keeping my options open
so this is essentially Occam's razor
yeah is this basically not committing
give a precise posterior belief you know
if I seen these data then I believe this
caused it so you don't want to commit to
a very precise one so you've gotta find
the simplest the most accommodating
explanation for your data so that's
where the paradox if you like in terms
of whether you're trying to maximize or
minimize the entropy term comes in I
think more fundamentally makes the point
that the entropy we're talking about at
the moment is a functional or a scalar
functional of a belief about something
is it's not the thing that is encoding
those beliefs is not the neuronal firing
all the molecules or the atoms the the
twist the the other sort of the the
slightly paradoxical aspect of this is
when you move into the future and when
you have the beliefs about the
consequences of an action say looking
over there or googling him you know a
certain entry in or going to Wikipedia
before you make that action you haven't
you you have beliefs about how your free
energy is going to change and at that
point your entropy or your relative
entropy is effectively switch around
because the outcomes now become random
variables you have to take an
expectation this is a bit technical but
it's a beautiful yeah little bit of
techie stuff which basically flips this
imperative to minimize these entropy and
relative entropy
yeah okay when you're applying it to the
system as it is now largest is behaving
when the system looks at itself say well
how would I have to now act in order to
minimize my fear in the future I now
include basically outcomes as random
variables and and they get into the
expectation operators and and suddenly
you're then in the service of minimizing
an amazing you know no other so there's
this sort of yin-yang which means that
as I'm currently processing my data I'm
striving to find the explanations that
maximize my uncertainty because I don't
want to commit to a particular belief
yet at the same time I'm going in the
exactly opposite direction and trying to
sample those data that will shrink
certainty and then when I find that
balance then we have this active self
evidencing let me let me try to put it
in my words and you can tell me if I've
come in close here I mean you we want to
minimize the times that were surprised
you might think well just predict the
thing you think is most likely to be
true all the time and but if you put a
hundred percent probability on that then
any time you're not exactly right you're
hugely surprised and that's bad so you
might say well let's do the other thing
let's have no beliefs about anything
let's say anything could happen but then
in some cases especially when you go
through the math you're always surprised
everything that happens is a little bit
unlikely because it could have been
anything else and so there's this
compromise where you sort of try to home
in on something you think is most likely
but you do give allowance for the
deviations absolute beautiful
beautifully put and I just yeah as a
sort of physicist what what what you
could understand what you've just said
as is basically how do we describe
systems that have some itinerant see but
they still restrict themselves to an
you're a limited part of their face
space of their state space so it's not
one point yeah we're not we're not
little marbles or moon rocks nor are we
gases there we are
We certainly have boundaries and we have
a shape and a form in the sense of you
know those parts of the state space we
could occupy or where the woodlice are
running around the others are structure
there
so that's structure if it is the case
that these sorts of systems exist things
like you and me or anything actually
exists in a non-trivial way by not
really I mean basically having an
attractive set that is a just one they'd
be in one state deterministic absolutely
yeah
then there has to be this balance
between the side tenancy this sort of
the you know the expiration of a phase
space in a structured way where many
regions are visited but some regions are
visited more often than other regions
and when you start to think about well
how would you articulate that
mathematically you start to get sort of
random attractors you know that inherit
from undeniable systems the wait a
second is there there's an attracting
set out there it is not it's probability
distribution if I measure the
probability of finding me at any point
in my state space over over a very long
period of time it's certainly not
uniform my house absolutely and yet I am
NOT a fixed point you know I'm not just
in one state so what you are talking
about effectively is a non equilibrium
steady state so it is not the kind of
equilibrium steady states that
physicists knew and loved and know and
love and and and were taught in the 20th
century this is the you know the new
charity of understanding non equilibrium
steady state from in open systems that
exactly have this delicate balance
between a being a point attractor and
being completely diffused the end of the
universe that's fast yeah it's good just
parenthetically I did have Antonio
Damasio in the podcast a little while
and and his favorite word in the
universe is homeostasis right the idea
of keeping within this tiny little range
as much as we can but some flexibility
there yeah and you want to do if correct
me if I'm wrong again but you really
want to say that this minimization of
free energy and surprisal is sort of the
key to unlocking what the brain does
right it's the it's the underlying thing
for most everything yeah there's a a
joke and my group meetings that the
answer to any question is model evidence
and certainly what are you talking about
colleagues and research fellows and you
know whenever they ask the question well
well what happens if this is like that
well get the evidence for that
hypothesis and then you know and then
you can quantify your beliefs about
whether it was like that or whether it
broke like that or whether that
difference is in play so can I come back
with another parenthesis because I think
it nicely aerosol from Terry DiMaggio's
focus on homeostasis of course the roots
of much of self-organization - non
equilibrium steady state inherit from
the work of people I Ross Ashby who made
apparent his ideas through the
homeostatic
so it's exactly the same or the good
regulator theorem I think this is a this
is just my personal opinion I think that
physics has a lot of work to do and
there's a lot of discoveries to be made
along exactly these lines you know we're
non equilibrium statistical mechanics is
a booming growth field that I tried to
get my colleagues excited about it but
it's a you know they're used to doing
their things it's it's a tricky kind of
pre paradigmatic area where we don't
exactly know it's a nice way to phrase
it
I I don't know because I became a
psychologist the physics behind that but
certainly surfing the web that pre
paradigm attic thing that's next thing
yes exactly 21st century physics it's
much more comfortable when you know like
in particle physics or cosmology where I
was raised you know what the questions
are you know what would qualify as an
insight where as in complex systems
dissipative systems Ilya Prigogine was a
early pioneer here also right
self-organization and we just don't know
what words to use we don't know what
equations to use but it I think like you
I'm a fan of these sort of statistical
mechanical lenses at which to view these
things yes well I'm sure that's the only
really - well for me is the only way to
write these things down because at the
end of the day you actually have to have
a model in code that generates
predictions to analyze the brain unless
you're a philosopher or you write polls
you need to be able to give it to a
computer and ask it how well you're
doing yeah but let's just do the sort of
the reality check for this perspective
here I certainly get that if I'm driving
down the street I would like to be
surprised as little as possible but
isn't it true that also informally I do
sometimes seek out new experiences right
how does that fit in well it's exactly
that sort of paradigm
we're dressing technically and tells the
difference between we mean at this point
in time this moment minimizing my free
energy via a maximization of the entropy
uncertainty of my explanations or
beliefs about what's going on now and
choosing those actions that will in the
future minimize my expected free energy
so that basically means that when you
talk about the expected free energy
conditioned upon a particular action
move you know looking over there when
we're driving the car you have this
opposite imperative so now you become
information-seeking now you become a
curious creature now you become
sensation-seeking
but it's a good particular kind of
sensation-seeking it's those sensations
that would resolve uncertainty about
what would happen if I did that because
behind a lot of the ways I've just
described that it is a sense of me as an
agent for so once you generalize the
non-equilibrium physics of sentient
systems to write down what might be the
imperative for the way that they act
upon the world that they evidence their
agency and you make the assumption that
or you try to prove that kind of you
know can be no other way that they will
act in the service of minimizing the
long term average of free energy in the
future then you get this curiosity
written into the did the information
theory to resolve uncertainty means
you're going to be sensation-seeking
whether that's the sensation-seeking of
a of a banal thought that you're looking
at this the traffic lights on the street
lamps to see whether it's go I'll stop
or whether it's going to a disco or
doing bungee jumping it's the same
imperative but this is the response to
the sort of the wisecrack that if we
just went him into my surprise we would
sit in a dark room and not do anything
right because but it's it how innocent
is that move to go from minimizing
surprise to minimizing the expectation
value of all my future surprises that
seems like a little bit of a different
minimization is that fair which one is
it that we're doing
well in a minimal sense you're doing
both buu you're sort of touching on sort
of the issues that normally come to the
end of the what is the difference
between you and a virus so to cut to
that that distinction but before
revisiting the fundaments of of
minimizing expected to be energy in the
future it may be the case that certain
systems certain particle systems
creatures basically have acquired the
capacity to include in install in their
generative models the pry belief that
they are free energy minimizing
creatures and if they can do that then
they will have the prior belief that the
way that I will act will be to minimize
my fear energy that was how it you would
might ride you down as the visitor she
was going yes good if you were a
psychologist all you're saying is I have
the capacity to plan yeah so that's all
you're saying what if you imagined
exactly yeah so you have sort of yeah
perfect so that's the you you're judging
model is now equipped with the capacity
to imagine a counterfactual effective
future and to imagine the future to roll
out possible consequences of actions and
of course the consequences of those
actions in terms of the observations now
are random variables because they
haven't happened you idea and that's why
you get this reversal and you know
suddenly you become a creature that
seeks out sensations literary sensation
seeking that resolve uncertainty you
become curious and you go to your
disappears new do your bungee jumping at
a certain age so that's I think an
important distinction between very
simple attracting sets let's go right
back to the moon rock okay so an
appropriate description of that
non-equilibrium said it's a is in fact
an agreement said it stage and that's
guys we've got a point attractor it
could have a craze a periodic attractor
so in the opening of the planet
but these are very simple non itinerant
attracting sets that would your approach
an equilibrium Studies stage then we
move up two systems right from sort of
rocks through to yeah I'm pretty may
even go as far as some not insects but
certainly same viruses so things that
don't plan mmm but they live them very
effective occupying our universe but
they live in the moment in some say
absolutely yeah gentlemen's were there
is no remembered present there is no
imagination there's no planning they
have all the mechanical finesse of a
thermostat and that they're very good at
what they do you know homeostasis yeah I
mean that's a nice beautiful example so
even in our own bodies though you have
possibly ninety-nine percent of all that
actually goes on in terms of the
physiology and you know which is home
stasis it's just this reflexive in the
moment keeping yourself by even
regulating themselves regulating
yourself so that those kinds of systems
are distinct I think from systems like
you and me that started planner and have
the ability to them their genitive
models do actually spun the future and
by implication the past they they
implicitly have a dynamics where the
trajectories actually go quite a long
way in or in their Jyothi model got
quite a long way into the future so that
would be a really interesting sort of
way to take forward the argument or a
response to your question but your
question is slightly just to return so
well is it minimizing free energy or is
it minimizing the free energy
conditioned upon a particular expected
respect to action it it is both the
degree to which you actively minimize
your uncertainty depends really upon the
shape of the attractor that we're
talking about the attracting step they
were talking about so
in Iran systems it is possible to write
down the density dynamics and work out
the probability distribution of
trajectories of action into the future
so this just accesses another state you
can apply actuation theorems or path
integral formulas UM's to work out a
distribution over trajectories of
actually into the state into the future
my point is what which means that
technically what you can do now is
characterize a given system in terms of
probability distributions over causes of
action policies into the future
trajectories or paths of action under a
model of what would what would what
would the implications of that
particular action have for my sensory
input for example when you write that
down that there is a there is a way of
showing that that is essentially a
description of systems that do minimize
their expected free energy in the sense
of just minimizing the distantly the KO
divergence between where they think they
are probabilistic ly they're attracting
set okay so that's one part of expected
free energy there is another part which
which is all about ambiguity reducing
which is kicks in when there are
particular constraints on the shape of
this of this probability distribution
that you and I Vince just by existing
and that depends really upon the
itinerant see and in which you can
measure in terms of reach informations
or relative entropy between different
partitions of the states details here
here come's little D so all of this
rests upon
Markovian partition into a Markov
blanketed in all rests upon carving the
universe into internal states that are
inside you that constitute your internal
states the rest of the universe and then
crucially blanket states that separates
in Sidney you from the rest of the
universe that enable you to be
identified and a further by partition on
those blanket states and interactive in
sensory states so once you've
compartmentalizing compartmentalizing
the different kinds of states that would
be necessary to describe a universe in
which something exists are you in a way
that is separable from not you then you
can start to write down you can go
beyond just the 20th century physics in
terms of entropy and relative entropy of
distributions of say an idealized gas or
some sort of closed system now you have
to deal with the entropy of a partition
and furthermore you've got the relative
entropy is now so suddenly you're in a
game of which is pure physics it's just
now you've got to think about the
relative entropy you can't just talk
about the entropy of this on cycle or
this they own the entropy of this
especially with this wave function on
this solution
you now have to carve it up and talk
about the relative entropy which is
where the information theoretic and all
the information richness and all the
uncertainty that's where it all starts
to kick in and of course in so doing
you've actually now committed yourself
to under to a mechanics of open systems
because the whole point of having the
Markov blanket is that it it enables a
two-way traffic between the inside and
the outside so now by definition you're
in the game of writing down these
statistical mechanics of open systems
that have some non equilibrium that he
stayed in virtue of having an attracting
set so now the game becomes well what
different kinds of attracting SEC could
be and if they are what would it look as
if they are doing in terms of these
mutual informations around been trapeze
or uncertainty resolving
pressures that you know are one way of
describing the very existence of this
attracting set I do want to get more
into the Markov blankets but I don't
want to quite let go of this transition
from living in the moment to living in
the expected future I guess that we this
seems to be without me planning
something that appears on the podcast
over and over again recently in a
conversation with the philosopher
Jeanine Ismael went in when we were
talking about free will and what that
means that came up and earlier with
Malcolm McIver who is a mechanical
engineer and neuroscientist
who has a theory that one of the steps
on the road to consciousness was when we
fish climbed up onto land and could
begin planning in the future because
there the life the time scales are much
slower on lands you have the ability to
plan so but so I wonder is it possible
in this framework to sort of pinpoint a
place in the evolutionary scheme where
we slip over from living in the moment
to being more planning animals my
personal theory is that it's with cats
because because I have two cats my
listeners are well aware Ariel and
Caliban and I swear that one of them
Caliban just lives in the moment like he
he his needs are being met or they're
not and that those the only two states
he has or as Ariel you could see that
she's trying to figure something out
about what would happen subjunctive ly
if she did something and like her little
kitty brain is trying its best so I'm
sure the cats is an exaggeration but is
is it as late as mammals where this
becomes important or do you want to
attribute it much earlier than that I
don't know but I'm compelled by you know
everything you said in terms of these
other perspectives you know particular
form philosophy makes entire sense to me
do the ability to you know to plan
suddenly means you have now a space of
trajectories causes of actions in the
future and it means that you have
because you can only
I realize one deterministic action
because action is actually a you're a
physical state of the universe it's not
an engine you know the action in and of
itself is not a belief we have the least
bad action but the action is realized
so that realization means that you have
to commit to one of a multitude so
there's a selection process in play
which must in some sense speak to the
free will or at least if he doesn't
depending upon your commitment that
excused a free will what he does say is
if there is a selection process in play
in terms of selecting an action from
some probability distribution or beliefs
about the way that I am currently acting
then it must be the case that only
applies to systems that actually have
posterior beliefs about the future yeah
he cannot develop a city on it feels so
a thermostat could not I think be
confused with something that might
Express freewill whereas your question
now is what point do we have biological
thermostats that have this beautiful
homeostasis then become equipped with
the capacity to imagine to plan to think
and as you intimated possibly may have
some minimal form of of consciousness my
own self about cell phone before
consciousness and so I normally recourse
to the philosophical notion of a vague
concept here so you know I only recently
learned about the whole philosophy of
vagueness is true we haven't talked
about on the podcast but that's an
interesting topic yeah so for those
people who don't like me who don't know
that like I was a few months ago so what
point is a pile of sand a pile you know
is it one two three four five grains so
I quite like that as a way of without
moving get yeah the question at one
point would you would you put your cap
threshold and I think it's warranted or
licensed mathematically because even
things like thermostats and viruses they
say protective coatings they predictive
coding does not have
planning it doesn't have this sense
maybe define for the audience predictive
coding
well predictive coding is just well
originally devised in the 1950s as a way
of compressing sound files so it's it's
a very efficient way of remote complying
with Occam's principle by make providing
the most retaining the most information
but in the simplest coding that you can
which is another way of algorithmic
compressibility yeah that is in fact the
free-energy principle as well they're
just written in terms of algorithmic
complexity minim message whether it's
exactly the same maths or different
difference of event spaces so predictive
coding as currently applied to things
like the brain is just the notion that
were minimizing our prediction error
yeah so hey so it doesn't talk about
action and what it does talk about is
how our brains might respond how our
since yes some decoders might respond to
some new data and they do it by sort of
reorganizing belief updating most state
estimation in a way that minimizes the
prediction error so if you can predict
what is currently being presented
currently exactly on the basis of what
you have previously seen then you must
have a perfect model of what is
generating that signal or that's Amtrak
or the you know that auditory stream
therefore you have minimized your free
energy or variational free energy or
you've maximized your evidence evidence
lower bound in terms of the pure sensory
the sentient aspects of it now notice
that we haven't which is you know the
important thing we haven't talked about
what we're gonna do I'm talking about
that yes so this you know that police
academy doesn't address active inference
it doesn't know active learning it it
just talks about sort of how to make
sense of data so that that would be a
nice example of you know the sensory
part of a virus or a thermostat and you
know it's it's
can be completely described as just
minimizing the discrepancy take a
thermostat for example let's now put
action back in into the mix so you can
describe a thermostat just as minimizing
as particular a petitioner between what
well between the temperature sensing and
its attracting fixed point so it's one
of these fixed point creatures and it's
got subtract and said it has its prior
belief the test to be like this and all
I need to do is to minimize my
prediction error minimize my free energy
and I don't know how I'm doing it but I
do say to you turning on the heater of
the original is but he's equipped with
action that will enable it to to get to
its fixed points so in what sense is
that planning if you remember I'm trying
to argue for a Vedas yes I don't have to
see your question well when when you
formulate that kinda pretty decoding in
terms of Kalman filtering or Bayesian
filtering which is there's be the
technical most efficient way of
describing a predictive coding scheme
you're always working with with
derivatives so it's you're always
working in a dynamical setting with not
just the prediction errors but the rate
of change of materials with time so in a
minimal sense you've got a notion of the
future through a linear first-order
approximation next incident anyway
absolutely yeah yeah so that's what I
meant with in a driven in a minimal
sense everything has every garrotted
model has a notion of the future just in
virtue of having a notion of detector is
dynamic yeah okay but it's not quite the
same as the old second cat yes not
thinking well if I that's right here
yeah you can see it's just at the level
of her capacities but but you mentioned
action and I think this is a natural
place to go there because you also want
to say that free energy helps us
understand how we behave is that safe to
say in fact so let me let me sort of
repeat the thing that I read and then
again you'll fix it one way of thinking
about what happens when I move my hand
is that my brain sort of intentionally
gets it wrong about where
my hand is and then there seems to be a
mismatch between where my hand actually
is and where my brain thinks it is and
rather than fix my brain I move my hand
to bring it to where it is is that
that's beautiful yeah yeah I don't need
to fix anything there in fact we should
celebrate that because what you've just
described is a modern day we count of
idea motor theory which was which was
prevalent in you know the 19th century
which Helmholtz yes well yeah yesterday
as a high entropy thinker yeah there
were other German neurologists and
natural scientists focus specifically on
oh I was picked up by William James on
his European Tour's but the I yeah I you
see exactly what you did said is this to
move I have to in my mind imagine the
outcome of that movement and then just
let my reflexes realize that imagined
outcome which basically was in the
Victorian era positives explanation for
stage hypnotism that you're you're are
visiting lighter and lighter and lighter
and lighter less and of course if you
believe your arm is getting lighter and
lighter and lighter and lighter is
floating then your predictions about the
proprioceptive input that you will get
if your hand was in fact floating can
now be fulfilled at a sort of pre
awareness level simply by reflexes and
your hand will in dangerous rise so yo
this is as much as nearly all the free
energy principle actually particularly
it's sort of incarnations when applied
to things like active inference these
are very old ideas you can actually
probably trace them back to the students
of Plato but they come through counted
held holds okay very much so
yeah and alongside that that sort of
perceptions inference is was this sort
of actions inference basically actions
beliefs about the way I should be oh yes
now I am like that and if of course you
actually tend to the evidence that in
fact your hand is not floating then of
course they won't move
which sort of takes us into the
interesting scenario that you must in
some sense attenuate the evidence
prevent yourself from getting that
exactly yeah okay as this is this
I guess maybe what we have the play-doh
or Helmholtz or William James did not
have is the ability to poke inside a
brain and see what's going on there is
this is this idea that action is driven
by a mismatch between model and sensory
input verified testable in the brain
yeah yeah absolutely a number of levels
but again just coming back to this sort
of notion that most of what emerges from
this promise that a mechanical treatment
of the bng principle was well known
century ago so what we are describing a
classical reflexes so there's just you
know the brain sends down messages to
alpha motor neurons in spinal cord
they're effectively are a mismatch
between the intended signals sensory
signals from the muscles the motor plant
and for it's actually receiving and then
those cells in elaborate signals to the
muscles to cause them to contract until
the signals match so the way that we
move and in fact the way that we secrete
our autonomic function works whether our
heart works in fact all of our
homeostasis works generalized our most
basic works is by supplying the right
set points to servos or homeostatic or
reflex mechanisms in the periphery hmm
what are those set points they're just
predictions of the way I want to be and
is the role of this free energy have a
role here in kind of an optimization
problem or an efficiency maybe mechanism
like there's different ways you could
imagine the brain or the the nervous
system bringing this match between
expectation and reality but is there
just a sort of they're easier ways to
calculate how to do that using free
energy using well I mean you're the free
energy formalism is if the grandfather's
all of these particular manifestations
I guess what you're asking is if I
wanted to now describe the the biology
or the wiring or the time constants what
you'd have to do is to write down the
genitive model if you remember the free
energy is a functional of a belief and
the belief is defined in relation to
agenda model so if you can write down
the gentle model you can then write down
the differential equations of these sort
of sensory and active internal space of
internal space you can associate neural
activity active states can be either
secretions or it could be physical
movements of a of an arm and then you
will be able to simulate these kinds of
phenomena ways and then do is take
empirical data and then change the
parameters of the generative model until
your simulation of an arm movement for
example or a neuronal responsive a
perceptual synthesis matches what you
what you observe in terms of brain
signals so that you know in a sense
that's another description what we
already do yes do we know we think about
the functional anatomy in terms of well
how does the brain model its world how
does it make these predictions how they
generate for example a movement how does
it generate these motor commands but
they're not motor can I was in his
predictions of why I should feel if I
was actually in this position or walking
or talking and in fact that industry of
not only theories of interpreting reflex
arts and the motor system under that
kind of perspective called the
equilibrium point hypothesis
there's also massive debates about you
know that reimplementation of that and
you know well that's the right way to
look at things I guess I had this
impression that you you might imagine
that what the brain is trying to do is
just use bayes's theorem it has some
beliefs it gets in more data it updates
its beliefs but that is calculation ly
difficult to computationally intensive
and calculating the energy is a sort of
shortcut you know minimizing the free
energy is calculation the easier than
simply conditional izing probabilities I
think yes you you've moved
to pay important observation sir so I
mean we've been talking about sort of
beliefs about where we should be and pry
beliefs and beliefs about the future and
cost pry beliefs
implicitly rests upon a Bayesian
distinction between my prior beliefs
pride to seeing any sensory states or
sensory data and posterior beliefs there
are the product of belief updating
having observers data so that is the
process of minimizing variational free
energy for example or is it not quite
hmm if you if that process of belief
updating and this just connected back to
physics so what we are saying is that
there is a gradient flow that is in
place that underwrites a random
attractor and that attracting set
defines the kind of thing that we are
under this Markov blanket or partition
in plane so that gradient flow we're
going to now associate with belief
updating on the assumption that some
states encode probability distributions
are standing for the parameters of
beliefs and once we've made that move
then we can actually write down the
gradient flows and in terms of belief
updating we just literally we're taking
a random dynamical system I'll say
long-run system and you know
interpreting the dynamics as belief
updating and the belief updating is from
prize do posteriors so that's a gradient
flow in this case is a way of saying
moving from the we are a little bit
closer to where we want to be yes yeah
absolutely well I mean that's exactly
what the free energy actually scores
yeah so we cover all sorts of wonderful
issues here so we haven't gotten to the
origin of life yet but we're gonna go
there too so yeah no it was difference
between Bayes and approximate inference
that's where we go but but I think
actually you're touching on something
which we'd rehearsed previously which is
another perspective on variation of free
energy so just for your interest
once you abandon
equilibrium physics 2340 20th century in
ethics and you just live in a world of
non-equilibrium steady state which
implies that there is some are crafting
step there and you have to explain it
you know it's mechanics then the the
free energy the variational free energy
now starts to have a look of feel of
something which is much closer to a
physicists thermodynamic free energy and
effectively it scores the divergence
between the current state of the system
and the probability distribution it
would have on its attracting set exactly
on the attracting sandhya so it's
basically how far away am i from my
attracting set or my non equilibrium
stand it's a probability distribution so
in that sense in now it looks very much
like the amount of energy available to
do work so I look at me i perturbed me I
put me in a highly unusual frightening
angst inducing situation I never did
before
you know home is statically or
conceptually and I will work towards
getting back to my comfort zone yes we
are a heavy place I have my right
temperature and in so doing I will
minimize my fee and I'll be working
literally on the environment so now the
to my mind there becomes an almost
invisible distinction between the
variational theology in the context of
writing down the dynamics or the
mechanics of non equilibrium steady
states with attracting sets and thermo
dynamic prematurely and in fact you can
just put it as a constant on and they
are the same thing and interesting the
Boltzmann constant is in the purely
information theoretic perspective it now
becomes just equips the amplitude of
random fluctuations with units and now
you can start to interpret it in terms
of you know there's a little measure
that's right
yeah this one measures anyway that was
that was me indulging myself do you like
it yeah but back to the you know why not
dissipate in inference
what's the difference between minimizing
free energy and base in inference
great questions so the the if basin
model evidence is just simply the
marginal likelihood of states of being
then one could vivvy let's say just by
optimizing the likelihood that i am in
this state which by definition is the
thing that i do because that's how i
exist i could describe myself as
performing Bayesian inference Tivoli so
because I can I can just call the
negative log of my non equilibrant same
density moral evidence and therefore
everything I do is in the service of
maximizing moral evidence I'm the
perfect basis of decision doesn't get
you anywhere but it's a nice a nice
thing to say so where does the
variational free-energy comes in
well the variational free-energy comes
in because it's operationally defines
what's called approximate Bayesian
inference so what's the difference
between Bayes Bayesian inference that
would conform to Bayes rule and
approximate Bayesian inference or
variational Bayes or sometimes called
ensemble learning but probably
variational basis is the most
technically correct term well the
difference is that you're not minimizing
model evidence they're maximizing model
evidence you are maximizing a lower
bound on model evidence which means that
the thing that you can measure which is
this variational free energy or the
negative end in machine learning is now
always a in machine learning it's always
below the actual thing you want to you
want to maximize which is your model
evidence but it's flip the side and
bring us back to physics and the free
energy principle so the negative
logarithm of moral evidence which is
essentially our self information our
surprisal can always be minimized as it
as if you were a perfect Bayesian
statistician by minimizing something
that's always provably larger than that
yeah and that's the KL divergence of
bound approximation so the very sharp
energy is an upper
evidence bound and if you minimize that
then you become an approximate Bayesian
inference why proximate well Custer's
the bound is not necessarily zero it's
not saturated yeah but that might be
easier to work that way that's the only
left off right yeah so it's just that
you the evaluation of the actual
evidence a partition function if you're
a physicist becomes intractable because
in high dimensional systems so how do
you elude that intractability what do
you actually got real physical systems
they would seem to be able to do this
kind of thing well you just created fact
it'll bound and who did that let you
find it that's that's that's the oh
that's where I came from right all on
one reading of the legacy there's
another right yes on one reading of the
legacy of physics for things like the
free energy principle and certainly a
machine learning that's using this
violence path integral formulation which
introduced the notion of a variational
bound a bound was using variational
calculus was provably always greater
than the thing you wanted to optimize so
you just optimized the doubt instead and
you get into some nice rhetoric about
sort of bounded rationality economics
okay you thought of that but I guess I
think so it's not it's not perfectly
rational it's not exact beat it in front
but it's doable physically realizable so
that's that's the key devlin of us is
Laplace is demon yeah yeah but so much
of this conversation and I think for
good reason has been in the context of
agents or brains occasionally
thermostats but you do want to be even a
little bit more ambitious right and and
talk about sort of a general organizing
principle of non-equilibrium systems to
minimize their free energy and maybe
this has something to do not just with
the nature of cells and organisms but
with their origin is that safe to say is
that a fair ambition to attribute to you
that minimizing free energy helps
explain why life came into existence in
the first place oh yeah you're taking me
out of my comfort it could be me could
be my lenses because I want to do that
ah you should talk about that yeah yeah
yeah well you know okay let's put it
this way you mentioned Markov blankets
right the idea of the you know in fact
we have a bunch of systems in the
universe that have a pretty clear
boundary between themselves and the rest
of the world right in this boundary
mediates their interactions with the
world the appearance of cell walls is
clearly one of the most important steps
in the origin of life and and a literal
cell wall is certainly similar in spirit
if not exactly identical to the the
conceptual Markov blanket between the
inside and the outside is that does that
safe to say absolutely yeah if and that
is the metaphor we always use and but
somehow life as we know it you could
imagine that if life were justifying to
some complex thing that had a big
chemical reaction and it evolved it
wouldn't need to have cell walls it
wouldn't need to be in a compartment and
yet it is as a matter of fact that I'm
wondering if if somehow being
compartmentalized like that affords a
special set of powers to certain
chemical reactions to then go and adapt
in in a crazy world yes
I'm sure that's right I I'm not sure
about I I I'm wondering whether there's
a slightly more deflationary way it's
very likely yeah you know do in order to
exist and to have measurable
characteristics in this routine you'd
have to have a Markov blanket so from a
sort of weak anthropomorphic principle
point of view then you know it could
have been no other way well does a
hurricane have a mark up like it
interesting point I've been asked his
gear Gaia
no it doesn't know that's really
rotating not Nordic candle flames no
life so that's but oh I think this is
but they have characteristics some
characteristics yes however you could
say an eternal flame do I think you're
right i I think that's a you know from
from my perspective that that's a really
interesting
outstanding challenge I'm wondering
whether birkhoff's notions of warming
sets resolves that that you can actually
have a Markov blanket that renews itself
right however that's you know but in
some sense you know one of the reasons
why we don't count hurricanes or forest
fires as living is that they're not rich
with information right they're just
doing their thing and even the simplest
cell and you know in your language
Cary's model of the world around with it
right and and a forest fire does not
talk good yes no yeah and so somehow I
don't know how life began that some of
my friends are working on it you know I
do I do wonder whether or not we are
under emphasizing the important there's
there's debate in the origin of life
between
replication first where you imagine that
RNA or the information carrying thing
came first and then it sort of wrapped a
blanket around it and got energy and get
going there's another camp metabolism
first that said that the actually
extracting free energy in the physicists
sense from the environment was the first
thing that happened and only later did
it sort of get imprinted informational e
on to RNA and then put in a cell and
then there's the easy everyone agrees
that the easy part is making a cell wall
is just like a bilipid layer like that
that can just happen automatically so I
wonder if we're not you know under
selling the importance of that thing
that without that compartment without
that blanket the very notion of having a
view of the outside world having a
having a model even if it's very very
primitive is not really tenable if you
if you don't even have a difference
between self and other yes what does it
mean to have a view
well that's the deflationary aspect for
me it's beautiful
for me it says on quinion doesn't
landscape I media depth there's a
fundamental truth to that I haven't
really thought about this when we use
the the friendship principle to model
morphogenesis and cellular organization
it becomes meeting obvious you need RNA
and DNA as a charity model that's
certainly the case that when you're
talking about sort of multicellular
organizationally you cannot get a free
energy minimum minimum minimum from
coupled free energy minimizing Martin
off blankets without some shared
eternity model that how that is most
naturally written down in terms of some
genetic code so elevation perspective
that makes perfect sense that's what DNA
is good at doing or uh storing the
information so so perhaps you could
argue and perhaps you have already or
people have already the yes first of all
you need a Markov blanket yeah otherwise
there is no existence off the saw that
we're talking about but a but if if it
is the case that just you know the part
of having a Markov blanket means there
is a way of writing down the dynamics or
the mechanics that makes it look as if
there's a generative model they also
have to be something in the internal
space that plays a role of ejecta model
and it seems quite natural and you know
the things that endure over generations
or show that sort of attracting set with
a sense of I didn't see that coming
looks like reproduction then that that's
what we call RNA or DNA yeah same may
well be that the knee on the other side
of the coin of having a Markov blanket
and namely I must have an implicit Jotun
model or it looks as if my gradient
flows are on a variational
gradient and that the free energy
gradient and that free energy is a
function of a jointed model therefore
must be a biophysical encoding of that
that couldn't be Feynman that you need
something like RNA DNA sorry in order
you know to go hand in hand with the
Markov blanket yeah well I do you
appreciate you indulging me there but
there may be good then to sort of wrap
things up we can bring it back close to
where we started with going back to the
clinic out of the research environment
how does this perspective this point of
view of free energy minimization help us
understand not just the brain when it's
working but the brain when it's not
working I I recall schizophrenia is
something that you might be thinking
about but maybe other things as well yes
I mean my personal training and it's a
feeling but I have to work with I have
the pleasure of working with lots of its
I quarry so I think it's a lovely
question because it allows me to make
some simple points of so if Kant and
Helmholtz and everybody since that time
are right and effectively psychology is
inference consciousness is images alone
consciousness is inference psychology is
inference and psychiatry is
psychopathology that tells you by
definition that psychiatry is all about
broken inference false imprints and I
mean that in very literal sense that
basically inferring something is in
there when it is not like a delusion or
a Lusa nation or inferring something is
not there what it is like an agnosia
listen you're already denial that
something exists or part of my body
exists so just extending that notion
that nearly the nearly every psychiatric
and probably neurological syndrome can
be cast as an instance of false
inference suddenly gives you or puts
pressure on you to now derive a calculus
of how the brain works
that is framed in terms of beliefs and
inference so just a few examples always
covers in
it's a premium of the Atlantic's
inference but also you could be on
income manifest in a more subtle way
let's take Parkinson's disease let's
come back to our idea motor picture of
why and how we move i'm fir that my MA
arm is going to be over there i'm third
that in the next six hundred
milliseconds i gonna stand up and start
walking now if i make a false imprint in
you ate the evidence that i am not
moving i will never realize that prai
belief i will never form an intention to
move what's the movie on fine but if i'm
not moving
i cannot deny the sensory evidence that
i'm stuck in mobile because that's a
casting description of pockets yes yeah
and actually if you drill down on the
things that the the belief updating of
the neuronal level in actually
implicates directed you know the
neurotransmitters and chemicals that are
implicated in parkinson's disease so if
we just generalize this notion of false
inference when infants really under
writes your free will selection of what
to do next in terms of predictions about
what's to know how you're gonna feel
yourself move and talk and think and
feel including your gut feelings then
you've got a way now of writing down a
mechanics of psychiatry so in a way that
all other normative schemes do not you
know because it's actually articulated
in terms of probability distributions
because the if you remember it's all
about functionals it's all about things
like aint repairs and elites and
relevant fizzes and servantis police
about something then you know you've now
got a countless which is fit for purpose
to understand false simple solutions
nations and perceptions and the physics
that gives rise from those the physics
under writes the belief updating at
least this false inference so in the
past ten years that's hit me time and
time again you know why it is so useful
and if not it's essential to understand
sentience and it's a philosophical sense
and the failures of sentience that we
have
in psychiatry to understand those in on
a formal footing
you know calls for something like the
fangio principle and has it led to any
specific tactics for therapeutic hope
soon so it certainly led to and and I
may be misinterpreting this through the
way that I the things that I've asked to
review I just made two people who
committed or subscribe to the fear as
you principle so I don't say alternative
but solely from what I see in terms of
being asked to contribute to special
issues and on what I see in terms of
been asked to review for this specialist
psychiatric literature there has been a
sort of slight paradigm shift in the
past five years it also centers on
something called precision we mentioned
that very very briefly before when when
we were talking about the predictive
glue code coding plan implementation of
variational a bottle a Bayesian
inference by about minimizing variation
free energy so I talked about the
precision weighted prediction terrorism
so what what that basically means is
that you could have a mismatch between
what you predicted and what you sense
doesn't really matter right you know if
it's in the dark if I get a mismatch
between you know I thought I was seeing
a visual and we'll actually get is
darkness does that really matter because
there's no precise visual information
around so I actually now have to see the
darkness by inferring the precision the
signal-to-noise ratio effectively the
error bars and some exactly it is
exactly the error bars interestingly of
course that's 99 percent of the
challenge for statistical analysis it's
not measuring the droopy it's measuring
your uncertainty about it so but that's
that's interesting people at you come
home you have some emphasizes the
importance of what you've just what
we've just said for psychiatry getting
the error bars right is at the heart of
good inference if you braid the
capacitor to get your error bars spot-on
you're gonna get all
sorts of false typed Valen type 2 errors
false inferences there are things that
they were not on they are they're not
there when they are so that's where the
precision comes in it's literally the
sort of the you know the more precise
the title the error bars the less
precise the more dispersed or uncertain
you are about something horribly
particularly the precision of the
sensory eminence of hand for example or
the precision my beliefs how the
confidence with which I hold my prior
beliefs that I've been used to explain
these data that Mayor them may
themselves may or may not be precise so
but you have best men this precision so
in looks as if and this is the mini
paradigm shift I was talking about it
looks as if in psychiatry nearly all the
phonology in the psychopathology and
possibly a lot of the neuro chemistry is
like psychopharmacology can be explained
by failure to encode the precision this
the error bars mm-hmm
that makes a lot of sense because nearly
every treatment or Sony every
pharmacological treatment in psychiatry
targets those neurotransmitters that
have a modulatory effects so they don't
ins in themselves encode shifts in the
beliefs or expectations or averages they
encode changes in the sensitivity to
sensory input for example so notice
though those are exactly from the point
of view of predictive coding exactly the
biophysical mechanisms that would encode
your beliefs about the precision so what
does that tell you well it it tells you
first of all we should talk iya therapy
you know it's likely to be in broken
standard error estimators in the brain
so where are they and then you know that
you know once you know about the neuro
chemistry in the function hasn't made
the projection systems and the domains
of beliefs that are broken if you've got
anorexia nervosa its beliefs about your
body if you've got visual hallucinations
in might be a sort of a little body
disease or not getting psycho syndrome
but the same underlying mechanism should
be played just with different
neurotransmitters and different possibly
neuro degenerative processes so it does
give you a mechanistic focus so you can
start to move away from what as if you
like haunted psychiatry for centuries
which is as purely knows a lot
call describing descriptive approach to
a slightly more mechanistic
understanding we just started to is
preparative like so so that yeah so that
when he said is it currently affecting
treatment structures no it is pre
paradigmatic audit but I guess if you
came back in five to ten years then I
think you don't see evidence of where
that that term led in terms of possibly
reinvigorating the pharmaceutical
industry I say that very practically
something you won't know but it worries
a lot of people in my game so the farmer
have basically given up on psychiatry
and developing psychiatric drugs there's
no money to be made because there's no
progress
there's no mechanistic underpinning so
about three years ago they basically all
just pulled out well
no idea yeah so there is no active
research at all I mean this is expensive
research has millions of millions in
drugs for schizophrenia depression you
know which is a great shame and you can
see why because they don't know what to
target because there's no one's said
well it's gotta be this system well
that's that's the only reason Porton
they just don't see the direction
forward yes absolutely yeah and of
course they have to just do they have to
keep the money coming in to fund the
research but maybe this will propose the
direction forward in something that
would be the philosophy
yeah all right I think this is a
wonderful lesson to end on we should all
aspire to have our error bars brought in
as close alignment with reality as we
possibly can Carl Fuerst and thanks so
much for be on the podcast thank you
you